Even if you do have dependencies and assertions
that help you rule out large parts of state,
you may still end up with a multitude of individual origins
where a specific infection may come from.
While you can rule them out one after the other using the scientific method,
the question is of these origins are you going to look at first?
The idea is to look at the most likely origins first.
The question is what is a likely origin.
What possible origin should I look at first?
Here are a few guidelines: First and foremost, infections.
If you know that some origin is wrong, go for it.
Next is causes.
If you know that some state causes the failure,
because you can change it to another value.
Such if the failure goes away, .
which is something you can find out through Delta Debugging, for instance,
follow it.
Next up: Code smells--If you suspect some code to be wrong,
or you have gotten warnings from a static checker, go for it.
Next up is bug history.
If you know that some piece of code
has gotten a lot of problem reports lately,
chances are what you're looking at will be another problem report.
Next up is last changes.
Code that has changed recently is way more likely to have errors.
So go for code which has recently changed,
and go for the state that comes out of this code.
Finally, anomalies.
If some code shows abnormal behavior before reaching the failure,
for instance, by producing a log entry,
follow this one as well.
Of all these features infections are the strongest,
because they are sure indicators of errors,
followed by causes.
Any cause implies a way to possibly work around the failure.
As far as the others are concerned though,
this is up to you and the specific project.
In fact, this is where your knowledge about
the specific project and its domain and the code comes into play.
Being able to specifically focus on the most likely sources of a bug
makes you a debugging expert for the specific project.